[Music]  every year Animal Planet airs the Puppy  Bowl Puppy Bowl puppy bowls for people  who don't watch the Super Bowl and they  recreate it with puppies well for the  past two years we've ripped them off and  we've done a puppy version of our show  called puppy Conan it's fun people love  it so welcome back by popular demand  puppy Conan  [Applause]  there yeah yeah oh that is an exact  recruit recreation of during the  commercial breaks when Andy nine make  out and Andy eats my hair puppy oh yeah  now he's sad puppy Conan's first guest  direct from the Grammys its puppy  Pharrell Williams  it says here's his second guest puppy  duck dynasty star Phil Robertson  [Applause]  [Music]  we  [Applause]  here's puppy Conan's next guest please  welcome puppy Toronto Mayor Rob Ford  to beg to be honest  [Applause]  gentlemen it's fellow Canadian puppy  Justin Bieber and his crew puppy lil Z  and puppy lil scrappy  [Applause]  an amazing  what a fantastic show  [Applause]